dr. King's legacy is one of action its
action motivated by courage and most of
all by love he was a man of great faith
and he believed not just in the ideals
of the country but also the spirit of
people to make those ideals a reality he
more than anyone knew how hard the task
was he had set himself trying to change
the culture of a country that was based
on not just slavery but inequality that
had been baked into law this was a heavy
lift
he had tremendous faith that he could do
it we can look at that today at the
problems we're facing and see that no
matter how insurmountable they seem you
can start with one action and people
will join you people of goodwill and
faith will come together and they are
coming together to continue this legacy
the fight for justice and equality is an
ongoing one and King knew that he was
looking at history but he was also
looking ahead to what the country could
be but he knew that it was going to take
effort by every one of us and it was
going to take effort every day to make
the ideals of America a reality and to
keep them a reality when you look back
at the history of this country you see
tremendous progress and we have done
some wonderful things but we've also had
some tremendous backlash to some of the
best things that have ever happened to
us
going back centuries King knew that and
he saw that most importantly he'd lived
it he lived in the south he knew that
reality he knew the good people there
were often overwhelmed by people who
were clinging to history clinging to the
Past clinging frankly to a stale sterile
way of life that they thought was
benefiting them it hasn't changed
you know people are still stuck in that
mindset of thinking that things used to
be better they could only get back to a
time when things were stable and in
their view the right people were in
charge but King knew that that was a
time that really didn't benefit anyone
that we're all better when everyone
advances he also knew that this was hard
it was going to be hard work and it's
got to be ongoing work when King talked
about the other America he was talking
mostly about the racial divide but I
think we're still in that situation
today where we have people who too
easily let things divide us we're
divided by
we're divided economically we're still
divided racially in some very very deep
and fundamental ways in which we see the
problems of this country and King talked
about the need to step back from that
and to find the commonality that we all
share and come together I was born in
Greensboro and when I was very young the
students sit-in movement started at A&T
University there while I was too young
to remember that you know my parents
remember the students and the civic
leaders who were organizing that meeting
in the basement of my dad's church and
one other church in Greensboro King came
to North Carolina several times in the
early 60s to encourage that movement
because he knew that young people were
the heart of it they were the spirit of
it and they were going to pick up the
legacy that he was laying down and carry
it forward my dad was born in the 1930s
in rural North Carolina and when you
think about that time period you tend to
think about you know the beauty of
Eastern North Carolina and sort of a
peaceful life but under the surface it
was a very difficult time for minorities
for blacks in the south this is before
Miranda was even a case much less rights
that are established for all of us it
was before so many of the court cases
that established the due process that we
take for granted and so when you if you
were a black person in the 1930s Eastern
North Carolina on the wrong side of the
law the chance was very very good that
you weren't going to get the kind of due
process injustice that we all hope to
count on today that we hope is available
to everyone today and so oftentimes for
people caught in that situation the only
remedy was just to leave the area and my
grandfather would help them make that
change that's a very important lesson
that I learned from both my grandfather
and my father that if people can't count
on fundamental fairness within our
systems then they're lost they feel
outside of those structures and they
feel that they have nowhere to turn it's
been very important to me as a
prosecutor and as someone who's worked
within government to make sure that the
government that we have is one that
looks at everybody equally and treats
everyone with fundamental fairness
we're commemorating the 50th anniversary
of the death of dr. King this year and
those were difficult times and I
remember that event because it was
really one of the first events of
national significance that impacted me
as a child I was eight years old and I
remember that day in April I was driving
down the highway with my mother my
mother and had brought us kids to the
airport to drop my dad off for flight we
were riding home and the radio was
playing the usual music news of the day
and they broke in with an announcement
that dr. King had been shot and had died
and my brothers and I didn't really
understand the significance of that at
the time and my mother's reaction was
what struck us as British is driving
down the highway and she slowed down and
she just was so affected by it and I
remember that she pulled over to the
side of the road and she put her head
down on the steering wheel and she began
to cry and my brothers and I did not
know what to do to comfort her we did
not know what had happened and finally
she said to us you know dr. King has
been killed and she explained what that
meant and it was literally it was
literally as if the very air around us
had changed you know you have that
feeling of something that is of such
great importance when my dad came back
from the trip he told us that the pilot
had come on board with an announcement
that dr. King had died and on the plane
a number of people had begun to cry but
that some people in the plane had
actually clapped and we could not
comprehend this my brothers and I could
not comprehend how someone could clap
over the death of anyone and that was
the first time that my parents sat down
and had to explain to us about racism in
America and how everyone did not believe
in equality of all people and did not
support dr. King's goals and it was it
was as you can imagine heart-rending in
so many ways King's legacy is one of
great strength and great commitment we
look at all the wonderful things he was
able to accomplish I think that he
inspires so many people today because at
the time no one knew whether it was
going to work or not I mean
it's against changing the law changing
culture changing society are always high
so you look at his courage you look at
his perseverance you look at the deep
faith then he brought to this he was
first and foremost a man of deep and
fundamental faith and you see how he
inspired ordinary people to come
together and with the force of their
commitment literally change this country
at the same time you see people who were
not supporters of him at that time
obviously leading up to the events
leading up to his death change is
frightening for people people who
thought that they had a particular place
in society that they should be theirs
forever and someone comes along and says
no actually everyone deserves this place
at the table everyone is part of the
Beloved Community and you see the
lengths that people will go to to
protect their position - to fight
against change you see the lengths that
fear will take people two people were
fundamentally afraid of King's message
and what it might mean for losses in
their own lives and I think that's
that's a lesson for today as we look at
conflict and how to manage it and how
people react to the changes that we see
in our country over the years and even
now the way that people will cling to
their fears as opposed to opening their
hearts up to possibilities is something
that can never be discounted King's
death is a reminder of that but the
commitment and the perseverance and
strength of people ordinary people
working people young people who
literally change this country is also
something that we can't forget and we
can draw strength from it we see it we
see it now with the young people leading
all the movements black lives matter me
to the Parkland students the way that
they have come together and found their
voice and shared it with all of us and
that they're literally shifting the air
in this country now around these very
important issues is a legacy of King and
the civil rights movement we've made
great progress in this country and I'm
optimistic about America I always am I
look back at all the things we've been
able to achieve since the birth of this
country and I still think that our great
days
ahead of us and we can build on those we
can continue to advance I think that we
we always however have backlash whenever
we have great progress you will see the
pendulum swing back in many ways you'll
see fear taking over you'll see that
distrust of change taking over but then
you know people who are affected by that
will realize their own strength and they
will push the needle forward again I
think the people that we're seeing now
emerge as student leaders in 50 years
we're gonna be reviewing them and
looking back at how they have brought
this country further along the road to
equality and I'm looking forward to that
I can't wait to see what these young
people are doing